[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
bye
so
yeah hey here we are sorry about that i
had no [ __ ] idea what the hell was we
were fighting over this [ __ ]
i was telling her it wasn't going live
and yeah she's like does it what's this
doing what's this doing she's freaking
out she's jumping out her own ass and
i'm like going look
what how do you link the two together
just well there's a key
and i said that key must have changed no
no it didn't no it didn't change it
check the key check the key yeah but
it's weird because no it's the same it's
gonna be the same and i looked at it and
she looked like oh no it's different
i don't know why why it's different
because we've streamed a couple of times
it's like so you have to like change the
key every single time from obs
that's [ __ ] well here's i don't know
maybe that updates or changes for
security reasons every every couple
maybe so
maybe something like that yeah so
probably what it is well you'll know
in the future when you go to stream that
if there's a problem it's because that
key's changed well now i'm gonna have to
check it every single time
you're gonna be that anal about that
[ __ ] yes you're gonna worry about it
that much
do you remember who that you're to who
you're talking to right now all right
i broke the [ __ ] tripod i broke a
camera tripod that's another thing
like literally six minutes before three
o'clock
he's like i'm gonna like this i'm gonna
layer this
and he just broke it off of the tripod
and i'm like really
i got the camera sitting on a door i was
like can't you just leave things alone
i got the camera sitting on it on a
empty frame for doing um
shirts sitting right there yeah because
it's just it's the top part of the
camera like broke off
i could fix it though i could fix it
it's not it's an easy fix yeah
so uh one i mean other than all the
disasters we've had today check it out
tom and his mom got me a new office
chair
yeah brand new for an early birthday
present yeah
yeah yeah that was like the old chair
was got lumbar support
the old chair was [ __ ] the old chair
was [ __ ] ancient
so i'm like [ __ ] we need we need to
get her something for [ __ ] her coming
birthday
well anyway i was talking about that
earlier
and [ __ ] i saw that damn chair
she was we went on we went in on that
chair
yeah yeah that's good chair though it is
it's a really nice chair like i said
it's nice for my
knife from my back yeah i like some now
i'm just going to
go like this the whole time hopefully
it's not too distracting
oh another thing speaking of technical
issues i noticed that
the um the show we did about uh armin
maiva's the
uh the consensual cannibalism show for
some reason
on some applications like on my laptops
and on my desktop
it trimmed the first like hour and a
half off
so it's only like two hours um
apparently i looked up on
online and other people have had the
same problem but if you go
into like the video editor
the whole thing is still there it's just
for some reason every now and then like
youtube glitches out and just like
uh just trims it down to two hours for
whatever reason but the whole thing is
still there
so i had to go through there and like
you know i trimmed out like all the
you know coming soon [ __ ] at the
beginning and then like lengthened out
the end and it's still processing out
so as soon as the whole thing is back up
i'll like let you guys know because i
know some people like commented were
like hey we're the first
hour and 15 minutes or hour and a half
for the show go yeah we're still having
technical
problems we're [ __ ] ironing it all
out though it's just the
the idiosyncrasies involved with this
[ __ ] program but you know
and i hate idiosyncrasies idiosyncratic
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i want [ __ ] to work the same every
single time the way it's supposed to and
nothing does
it drives me crazy i got a [ __ ]
surprise for you guys
oh yeah we were talking about this [ __ ]
we were talking about this [ __ ] on the
show
[Laughter]
little debbie's that was another thing
he saw it [ __ ] little debbie's match
that's when i saw this come out of the
car it was like i saw those things and i
was just like oh i got i got a [ __ ]
show i got to put little debbies on the
show we're going to eat a little little
debbie
where's my knife do i have it in here i
don't know okay it's all right i'm going
to open this [ __ ]
man well that's what i usually do i
don't have time to
i don't have time to go get like blades
or anything like that
they're boxes inside boxes oh my god
well yeah that's for because
you got it from sam so yeah these are
the store for this door gotta be a
business owner to [ __ ]
get a sam's car yeah so we can just like
open that up and like sell it on our
like porch yeah
i'm going to have one of those with some
coffee later on that would be delicious
i haven't had one of these for forever
look at how many of them there are in
here well it says there's 24. look at
that
oh i didn't know there was two i thought
it was just one no that makes it even
better
all right oh [ __ ] like i said i'm not
gonna eat mine right now because
i'm gonna eat mine well of course you
are i don't have this is what they look
like i'm gonna get chocolate and [ __ ]
all over
you people that have never been to the
south this is some [ __ ] southern [ __ ]
here
i've been having these i'm gonna have
i'm gonna make a cup of coffee in a
minute and happen
after we finish recording i haven't had
one of these in more than 20 years maybe
twenty thousand speaking of little
debbie's sort of
remember how i said you were talking
about um
oh i'm gonna have one i'm gonna have one
later stop try it i'm gonna have one
later
he's so pushy um you remember we were
talking about the lady that was on
hoarders that you called moonpie
no on the saturday show and i said that
i was gonna put a picture of her in the
sunday show and i forgot
but i have one now okay yeah i couldn't
find like there weren't like a lot of
great pictures of her although she did
come
become like kind of a minor meme
celebrity like
called poop lady obviously because what
else would you call it i call it [ __ ]
moon pie but here's
no go back to that now wait a minute
where did it go where did it go
i don't know
it's season six episode four she was
[ __ ] in [ __ ]
containers and leaving it in her damn
house man she had thousands of gallons
and in the yard
so i'm sure the neighbors were super she
was a [ __ ] one-woman plague
yeah i like that these are good
it smells good these are they've
improved them
really they've improved them usually
everything gets suckier
there's a lot of peanut butter on them
well nothing wrong with that
not one bit wrong the germans wish they
could make some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no the germans make some good [ __ ] the
chocolate's a lot better
than it was yeah yeah i was trying to
let you chase them taste them on camera
no i meant no i'm not gonna
damn what the [ __ ] wrong with you
because i'm gonna eat on camera that's
gross
it's um the chocolate is not working
making me do stuff i don't want to do
making me see things i don't want to see
yeah exactly
the chocolate is a lot um creamier
yeah yeah remember it's not that 70s
waxy chocolate like we remember
there's a [ __ ] i know that's what i
just said it looks like a mosquito or
anything
what the [ __ ] thor's got his little tiny
net
well florida has yeah florida has all
kinds of bugs that are [ __ ]
all right so oh also i wanted to give a
shout out to
ken who i think that's you in the chat
right there who is our newest
patron just to join today so thank you
very much
thank you very much for your support i
almost got
some of the uh the oatmeal pies i'm not
as crazy about those
they were sold out but they came out i
guess everybody decided they're like hey
i'm just sitting around my house like
a little baby and i'm just right next to
them [ __ ] on their little knit little
dabbies on the
on the palate said oatmeal
pies that's what it said on the plaque
but they weren't there they were all
gone and you were like
[ __ ] denied next time get me some zebra
cakes
they didn't have those they had zingers
though no those are all right too yeah
well wait
wait a minute okay the lemon ones are
better than well the
chocolate ones are good too but the
lemon was in the same case you know
oh okay you walk down and have all the
candies where all the candy bars were
and [ __ ] i know i always try to avoid
that aisle because otherwise i'd be like
oh 40 pounds
don't mind if i do i was thinking about
those little debbies
that's why you shouldn't go he comes
down with like all this [ __ ]
like i said that makes me happy because
it seems like i i thought that i would
taste them and it would just taste like
sadness and disappointment
with two of these cases in that case had
two of these boxes
oh okay it was um four dollars four
dollars and sixty cents
get the [ __ ] out of here with that yeah
no wonder americans are so fat
back in the mississippi days this would
be this would cost you about a dollar
maybe two dollars i think 99 cents was
the was the box it was like a long box
like that and i think there was either
eight or twelve in there
like i said depending on yeah look at
all those men there you go
that's a [ __ ] bunch of diabetes right
there actually you could supply diabetes
to a whole family
diabetes is [ __ ] supplied
[Laughter]
it's like yeah yeah you have to go
looking for diabetes it comes to
finances
it's delivered to you free of charge
it's a requirement all the time timmy
says
hello well thomas they're happy yeah
you just go up for your diabetes test to
confirm
that the mission is diabetes yes
yes it's a [ __ ] mistake a little bit
or a whole [ __ ]
welcome to the deep south yeah yeah also
cholesterol
cholesterol yeah all right so we're
going to talk about this movie or what
yeah so this one
this was actually a happy surprise i
just picked this one this is actually
streaming for free
on 2b um it is an indie movie and it is
called abigail haunting
now i picked this one there's a lot of
other movies from 2020 that are on to be
surprisingly
and um you know there are a couple other
ones that looked good and stuff but i
was like i'm kind of in the more in the
mood for like a ghost story type of
[ __ ] so i decided on this one even
though you know the title is kind of
generic uh the artwork
is kind of generic you know what i mean
it kind of looks like a lot of other
kind of ghost story or possession type
movies
but when we uh started watching it it's
actually
really it was like way better than i was
expecting you know i don't
i don't know i don't know what i was
expecting but it actually was a lot
better than i expected
yeah i liked the movie yeah it was like
um it looked like it was shot in nevada
yeah and um written and directed by
kelly schwartz
and um also co-written by someone named
charisma
something charisma manumet malumet
something like that it was a really
weird name
so i don't know if this is their first
movie or what but um
the nice thing about it it's it seems
like it's pretty low budget
but you can't really tell like nothing
about it like screamed low budget at me
you know what i'm saying um you know the
acting is perfectly good
the cinematography was really nice the
score was really good
i loved that opening song like it was
all very
like nick cavey tinder dixie kind of uh
southwestern creepy kind of music i
really really liked that i dug it
yeah had good honest storytelling they
didn't you know didn't try to [ __ ]
get one over on you or anything they're
not trying to take a piece of [ __ ] and
turn it into something though here uh we
fooled you into watching this it's not
like that we fooled you in the back
it was good good old-fashioned good
solid storytelling you know um
the acting in it was good main character
is this
kind of cute little robber chick
named katie yeah trying to get out of a
damn bad relationship with a dude who's
robbing [ __ ]
she goes back home to where she grew up
with she grew up in this creepy ass
[ __ ] trailer
with the foster parents like she doesn't
know out in the desert
yeah and then it does feel like
something out of one of those dead mall
videos or the dead mall out in the
[ __ ] desert it does have a [ __ ]
it had a good tone to it and
it's it's it's just a good
low-budget movie well-made low-budget
movie you could tell they cared about it
it had
practical effects nose notes see cheap
cgi
yeah i think some of the ghost stuff was
cgi but it was
but you couldn't really tell it looked
really it looked good it didn't look
like cheesy
i kind of had kind of a believable
[ __ ] paranormal
activity type stuff you know what i mean
where it was you know psychokinesis or
you know rspk type
thing going on you know objects moving
feelings of being watched
um a feeling of a presence in the
[ __ ] trailers it's
it's good um there was just really
something that
i mean like i said it's not like a super
original story
it's basically a ghost story yeah um
you know so it's not like a really like
crazily like original story or anything
but i just there was something about it
the just the whole tone of it the
setting um
something about it like really kind of
struck me
you know what i mean it just got me
really invested i think something that
was good too was that the
opening like really hooked you right in
i mean the opening was like oh there's
been a robbery and then there's like a
double cross in like the first
two or three minutes yes they try to get
you and pull you into the movie
yeah so you can kind of so it really
kind of gets you involved in the story
the movie has real
common looking locations and common
looking people for like out in the
desert
uh it gives you kind of that weird
alienated feeling like you're in a real
[ __ ] po dunk town
yeah like you go out to and you they go
out for a drink and you see
that's what it looks like it's just like
yeah nothing
looked real hollywood or artificial it
was yeah i mean you could tell they just
use
real locations those were like
somebody's house that they knew
and yeah you know it's like somebody's
like old trailer house
yeah and there's no stars in the movie
which thank god there's no stars in the
damn movie i'm sick of [ __ ] stars
it's just
good at working actors and so you don't
associate them with other characters or
you know what i mean or any [ __ ] that
they said in social media or anything
it's just
people and they all look you know like
regular people
yeah i liked it yeah that's what i mean
so
so this basically the story like i said
there's kind of like a robbery at the
beginning which just like in the in the
prologue
which happens in reno and then um
the girl katie she kind of like runs off
and she has to go into hiding
so she goes to prescott nevada
and she doesn't really have anywhere to
go because she i guess she was an orphan
and she grew up in foster homes
so she goes back to uh the foster
home that she had stayed at now i don't
know if there was a dad involved they
didn't really talk about that but she
had a mom
a foster mom named marge so she goes
back to this trailer house where marge
lived and where she grew up and marge
ain't right uh basically she looks like
they don't really
specify at first like what's going on um
but it looks like oh her health is
deteriorated she basically just sits
around in her robe
and watches tv and never says anything
yeah didn't hardly talk
it's like every now and then she kind of
just gets up and shuffles off back to
her
bedroom or whatever so that i really
liked the setup of that because it was
like really creepy you didn't really
know like what is this woman's deal
is she possessed is there something that
matter with her and then like very very
slowly
like little supernatural [ __ ] starts
happening around the house you're not
sure if it's the mom
doing it when nobody's looking or if
there's like a ghost in there
or you know what's happening and then it
all kind of like ties back and then you
know um
katie like reconnects with uh this
other guy what was his name brian or i
can't remember what that character's
name was
but he was i guess he was her foster
brother so they kind of like grew up
together
or they knew each other somehow and um
so they kind of start hanging out more i
thought he was the neighbor
um he said that his uh he said that his
mom still lived down the street okay but
i thought yeah so i guess they knew each
other when they were growing up because
i think there was a scene where she was
looking through old pictures and there
was a picture of him and her
right so i don't know if he grew up in
the same house or grew up in the same
neighborhood
or it was like her old boyfriend or
something like that so they were just
like old friends i guess
and they had like lost track because she
had moved away and apparently got into
some bad situations
which they don't super go into but it's
just kind of like it's just kind of
mentioned
but i don't know it's just there's
something about this one that i really
really liked like i thought it was it's
not super long it's only an hour and 22
minutes
um i saw some reviews saying they
thought it was too slow but i didn't
really
get that i mean i've watched like a lot
way slower movies than this
after the initial opening scene about
the robbery thing and the shooting and
everything goes down
there's probably like a 10 minute
build up 10 to 15 minute build up i
could see how they might think that that
was kind of slow
but it's only in comparison to the rest
of the pace of the movie because the
rest of the movie moved
moved along pretty quickly so that's
what i thought i mean i thought it was
pretty well paced and like i said you
can't never i didn't get bored
that's what i mean i didn't so i got
tough standards about that
yeah so and i mean like i said you have
a good opening so already you're kind of
invested in this girl's character you're
like oh
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] is going on and
now she's like going into hiding and now
she goes back to her old like shitty old
house in her shitty old town
and like her foster mom is like acting
like super weird and also maybe there's
a ghost in the house and no one believes
her
so i didn't really feel like you know
that yeah there's some character
development there's like you know her
and the guy like going out for
you know drinks or whatever but
everything is kind of leading up to
you know the [ __ ] that happens at the
end it's like it kind of gets crazy at
the end but not crazy but
you know all the ghosty [ __ ] like
happens more towards the end more
towards the end but i feel like most of
ghost movies like that because you have
to build character up you have to like
build [ __ ] up slowly you can't just like
be like hey ghosts everywhere like from
the beginning because then it's not
scary anymore it like loses its
appeal it's just a good solid low budget
independent movie
that's that's how i and to be honest i
looked i looked on youtube and i think
we're the only people that have reviewed
this
yeah like i looked on there and there
was tray there was a bunch of trailers
and um also i think somebody or a couple
people like put the whole thing up
for free um i don't know i didn't watch
it so i don't know if it was real or
one of those fake ones but um i mean you
can watch it for free anyway because
it's on 2b
but it's just really strange the way see
you never know like with the 2b movies
because
you there's all these movies on there
they have new ones they have old ones
they have all this kind of [ __ ]
and this one like i said it didn't the
artwork didn't really stand out the
title didn't really stand out
um i just picked it because it was new
and i said oh it sounds like a
haunting type of movie a ghost type of
movie and that was what i was in the
mood for
and it actually ended up being really
really good and it's like
it just goes to show that i mean you
know it happens you never know what
you're gonna you never know what you're
gonna get it's like because sometimes i
see something that looks decent and then
i watch it i'm like oh that's terrible
that was stupid like the damn clowns one
one bottle of the cloud that's terrible
clown fair clown
yeah that one the trailer looks good
trailer looked great yeah
and then when we watched it what the
[ __ ] i was like oh
damn terrible that was really not good
the only thing that i liked about that
one was
the i don't know if it was the set
design of the clown hotel or if there is
an
actual clown hotel somewhere where they
shot it at that was pretty amazing
looking
but other than that i was just like i
could hardly get through it
yeah this isn't just a hidden gem yeah
it really did strike me now and i love
when that happens i love when it's like
there's a movie that i
hadn't really heard of and i didn't
really and i just kind of picked it at
random and i was like hey that was
pretty [ __ ] good
i don't know this company i don't know
the studio i don't know the [ __ ]
director don't know any of these people
but yeah yeah look good
but like you know and we say this all
the time good movie
you know but there's all these people
out there making movies
and you know a lot of them suck yeah but
every now and then you come across one
that's
pretty [ __ ] decent yeah and that kind
of makes me happy when that happens
so you know i'm gonna look out for more
uh movies from
from these uh writers and directors
because i really really did enjoy this
one very much
like i said it's not a super original
story it's just basically a straight
ahead ghost story
that's kind of set out in the desert but
you can tell that
you know they really put all their heart
and soul into this and
you know i i really liked it a lot so
you know yeah
there's a surprise that no one else has
reviewed it me too
i don't know yeah it came out this year
i mean usually
i don't know because some of the movies
we picked on to be
um i haven't seen that many reviews of
them thank you matt
thanks man um i haven't seen that many
reviews sometimes i can just find one or
two
but this one i didn't see any unless
they're like wait